welcome back to man over Midtown part
three this game is a beat I'm on my
honeymoon right now how does that work
I'm like squeezing in one more episode
before I go because I want to play damn
it I want to know what's gonna happen to
Julia how is she gonna die oh by the way
if you guys haven't checked out 100
million club merch is out now I know
it's kind of shameless for me to promote
it at the beginning of the episode ah
see that's what happens when you don't
wear 100 million club merch good joke
good joke it looks very cool and it's a
great way to support channel that's all
I'm gonna say all right moving on
seriously watching these caskets why
would they be chained and locked well
that's what it's gonna be you Jule yeah
it's gonna be you Julia if you don't
shape up I'm tired this is gonna be
hilarious I got to hit those QuickTime
events though
look I hate they seriously are you
trying to freak me out
[Music]
just get out home that's the second time
that happens my god it's just a bass on
vas as it's called in France who never
says it's called in French people
yeah it's a little glitch that it locks
up sometimes I'm sure they fixed it in
the folder I'm playing an early version
because I'm mapping really Juilliard
really I feel like people named place
could die I don't mean that in a bad way
it's just like it just sounds like a
character in a movie life is expendable
if I mean it can span these expressions
Weiss or [ __ ] and span you hear that
first
I'm gonna be so minutes the [ __ ] gear
is gonna be old really you want to say
anything else more redundant you will
find old stuff and an old [ __ ] that's
still might have some cake four years of
med school and prescribe me an 80 year
old aspirin I call me in the morning
that's not gonna make him sick is it
that's a good question would it
I wonder if that's had any effect
also 100 million we hit it gamers I
probably won't have time to make a video
oh god this is no time to be [ __ ]
around I'm serious
I won't have time to react properly make
a video
you got a poke it to know if it's real
otherwise how do you know
seriously gamers jula you just know to
span sport bearing here is their
contract must have gone on the head head
there's no penis sorry there's no
creeper oh oh do you think that's a
little brother maybe it is it'll be like
a plot twist little brother evil good
plotters right no one expected a lot of
brothers sorry bro
[Music]
well you gotta get the go with it that's
a good that's a good point
now I don't mean to be sexist and but
they could have given her better pants
that's all I'm saying
they could have given a little slightly
longer pants I don't think those pants
could be any shorter
and we're going fishing hurry you don't
even know what you're doing you just do
whatever he tells you don't you Oh
little do you know I'm crazy I go in
circles for no weeks what happens if you
challenging come on that's cool that's a
nice d-10
our challenge any further though
places like this is like plenty of rooms
to make your escape stop like that
you're finna die stop
sometimes this game really fools me and
I feel like I'm actually watching a
movie and that's really cool
playing a movie I should say
it was an optical illusion
haha dammit all this trick in the book
unbelievable
these [ __ ] places first
smart you just looked at of sack of
potatoes there's something minecraft
batter this madam what is this wheel me
what did I do
[Music]
what are you talking about I don't want
to hear anything from you you just tell
me that's dangerous
whoa see see that's what happens
literally told I tried to warn him but
he wouldn't listen
jezus huh yeah the same react Christ oh
Christ
that guy that guy's probably still like
here with us
I mean you die ownership your boss stays
on the ship yeah sure if no idea what
you're talking about
you made the same reference before about
the boat in there of ocean oh my god i
am i don't know what the [ __ ] this is
all about but we gotta keep moving and
find olsen now how did they get split up
to begin with
oh [ __ ] man
yes get to fail soon back al Oh Suzanne
Khomeini
Kawai
all right what is this one day hey hey
potato on my Schneider what that freaky
do good can i Sudoku
dude bro let me this is so not fair
alright alright
you like that you like that wall what's
a question for down
[Music]
doing a pro-gamer move the hell you must
have seen something
yeah go in their line of sight of the
fire good idea
cringe she has the same type of tattoo
it is realized as the other boys maybe
it's a native tattoo that on
oh never can watch haha yeah okay bone
man
big whoo bone man speaking of which wait
she's walking I don't even want her to
know we all owe a damn I'm good at games
give me enough credit
is anyone there anytime you say that you
know someone's there if anyone's a just
say just like freak them out do
something weird but up something
masturbating we'd buy your dick goes be
like I don't want to sometimes she's
like sign like that's smart
didn't even hesitate
where was the bad place to be it was it
not in cargo shiny Jesus what I've been
down here damn bro you look weird bro
jump-scare
in 3 2 1
surprise me mr. Paris
you disappoint me 360
[Music]
nay happy [ __ ] Bradshaw he's not a bad
guy
[ __ ] alright alright let's go let's go
gamers let's go [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
[ __ ] come on war
[Music]
I go back in the book
[Music]
making a vanity do to be it's to movie
he's in Minecraft
holy [ __ ]
hey we've been here
so what is his plan he doesn't have a
weapon he doesn't have anything in this
guy
no reaction from one of us was there god
this can't be good
no bueno
I mean it could be good if it was all a
prank maybe this is like scare PewDiePie
season 3 or some change oh yeah she lost
it
that's right truly is they were here
okay they were here Julia
nope cool
you a pro-gamer move suppose you can go
down here
yeah all right I ride I ride I ride
here we go nope hello
Oh
this is really cool this makes me want
to play a song
[Music]
[ __ ] shamrock [ __ ] on a shamrock that's
a weapon here hey girl judge may 9 year
old well that must have been summer
spooky Dookie
[Music]
it's doing that thing again I need to
right-click when it happens I think the
game taps me out or something
us generally
all right
yep you what a bunch of BP's on my great
perfect
well my psych psych party we did
paintball and at the end of it they were
gonna yell out free-for-all so everyone
just goes against everyone but so many
of us were just [ __ ] so we just ran
to the safe zone oh my god to me jack
dave and joel we're just sitting in the
safe zone and we like yeah if there's
ever war we're gonna be the people that
run hello what in the hell was that
what the hell was that you know I
understand people want privacy in the
bathroom that's all it's all good right
no apparently not according to this guy
hey you were okay
don't look in the no not here
hello not for some reason I can go in
there well this is awkward for like 22
[Music]
toilet to Nima's s okay I'm good at this
boom-boom-boom those look like feminine
feet could that be fluffy or whatever
her name is I don't want to mess up
anyway
is that an eyeful of whose feet forgot
her name sorry texter doesn't want to
load sometimes it kind of sucks
this is classic Silent Hill scare you
think it's over it's not gonna do that
again is it
Oh epic hit back okay I did it
put your head in first come on be an
alpha
can't seem to
where should I go you kind of like sways
towards I thought for sure you would be
able to go in here now
and we can't go here why is this so
confusing
everything else has been so flowing like
the toilet all right guess we'll go back
you guys remember that's scary I keep
referencing it inside a home when
BitLocker and you go out and then it
scares you so good why in the world was
that defend a future John now
to be proud of something no will throw
your life away for something greater
an imagery of what is good equipment
requisition form they need gas masks
you remember the two guys in the
beginning and one of them had to get
like sedated or something garlic mustard
horseradish mister yes
six-one
mustard gas smells like garlic maybe
they're through here
I mean it need something to help me get
up there do you always talk to yourself
Brad or is it just like because I'm here
got'em damn I'm getting fast gamers
these fingers be clicking
like the only one that places on
computer tom if it's your ass
oh sorry if Tom it's your ass if this
gets out see that it's done it's your
ass okay
epic well I sure hope that got resolved
I'm pretty sure that Inc would have
faded by now game
all right what about that box that
they'll notice
this is my favorite part of games I like
that
everyone likes name
absolutely
so how are you guys doing Alex Juliet
hello Jane good summer epic looking
forward to go back to school or nine
there we go is it premonition
cool there will be a helicopter so
things will get more and more crazy yeah
we still have bone man to arrive
it has to be an evil character plot
twist as well right am I crazy or am I
just stupid maybe this is Forrest Gump
shrimp ship damn we're playing a lot is
this guy what's this deal something over
here
and skeletons skeletons
skeletons that's good writing that's
good writing skeletons skeletons
skeletons hey could you record this line
for me
it's a skeletons skeletons skeletons I
have to throw this nice this good step
how about a skeleton skeleton skeleton
skeleton sort of altercation
I'm just joking by the way sorry you
asked to keep to be kept informed of the
radio situation we attempted outgoing
messages at the following times with no
response
happen
private Koopa he's not even a skeleton
am I wrong for thinking the wrench is a
Swedish invention by the way Alex
Julia that looks like mustard gas
come on Fred Oh Fred you pricked up all
right
everyone is still alive everyone's still
alive
we're back with no pen Karl everyone
everyone's gonna be pantless at some
point in life so might as well be Oh God
can you walk
thank you
oh wait was that enough right that look
like Brad he's going on here does that
mean Brad is gonna dare we all
what is that pull it you get it back boy
or girl
or skeleton people
Oh how many germs in this place
disgusting ah don't touch me
see
what else do you want me to click cuz
I'll click it
punch dose up big place Thanks tell them
to break off place that was Brad I was
right but he's now this is like a shiny
beautiful
man I'm so lucky playing awesome games
as my German titties
but see anything can scare in this game
now Oh freak now close close the door
close the no don't do dare for the
quarter in there I swear I swore to your
flesh flesh do not press that button
place unbelievable
fa I like that your jump list let's be
like okay so zombies just try to eat me
so maybe I should put it not right it's
not one of these books I just met down
on it blip blop blip blop blip blop blip
up please do you think you have enough
bracelets
so these are the books that I failed to
open the other time it's a little bit
too much reading for me so that's the
guy that reads it's just it ruins to
blow with the video if you want a powers
you can powers
can't walk here for some reason
place is there something there oh there
is sorry and see it is ain't right it's
a bear okey this keep your head on
straight
okay please
you heard your shop keep your head on
straight I got a bad feeling about this
I think we're supposed to go in the
other but yeah let's explore a bit more
plus you know on here place I am talking
to myself right now stop doing the same
Oh
[Music]
I really like these games cuz horror
genre is so dry it out in my opinion I
like that these guys are doing something
different I get this format really suits
it's not like I'm scared out of my mind
but it's just fun I think so many horror
games are just the same these days such
a shame that PT never came out like that
could have really done a lot for the
horror genre in my opinion right now
it's very uninspiring it's an octopus
all right Julia gonna take swim so not
gazelle hog did you read that why am i
naming game wasn't it electricity
already working oh man
creeper comes out oh man so way back in
the mind God appeared yes yeah I am yes
your name is weird Felice not anything
else
my name is not weird
oh they're bout that's my name
say it right
are you ready for a jump scare scarcely
again people up drinking
creepy there's no real main character of
the story
[Music]
made it out huh
what rot their shoe
come on it was so nice and peaceful
trying to reach this oh it's the gold
well well well we found a gold epic that
was a secret
what's inside there this is not where
Brad jump down
what happened that was a guy in the back
or am I crazy yeah it is Fred what up
dog Brad pick it up Hey
[Music]
whoa Fred stop you're crazy he's crazy
hmm I mean it happens to everyone every
once in a while all right we're back
with Juliet
[Music]
that's a program
that's cool that's a cool shot oh that's
really dumb do you guys ever hate when
you're in a haunted boat and
should probably focus is that her
don't worry more about breathing if I
were you but you know the skeleton
you're gonna help Juliet
come on damn
let's go and Julia you really did it
there well done
that was good
is there an option to not help her
what you you okay
Thanks I could have drowned we got to
get away he's still around that guy
[Music]
he's got his eye Bank Joey
let's go
come on to be one Juliet name if you
ever mess with me and mud set we will
take you out my scent will bite your leg
and I'll scratch your face no I think
it's funny but I think the guys you
hired are taking it a little too far
maybe and don't be cheap you feel like
paying top dollar and you get these guys
or not cream the crop they're taking it
a little too far though you know my
drift
so if you want to feel free to pull the
old plug get rid of these guys I'm with
you I mean it's all the same those ass
crazy they're chasing it's [ __ ]
[Music]
I have a feeling this guy's gonna die
because we played almost three hours and
there's not even anyone dying he's
something something freakin
you should I go in these rooms
[Music]
this is they freak you you freak them
out yes grab that that's a weapon please
grab it you need a weapon
grab it come on
what is this problem that's the
strangest thing that has happened on
this boat so far I saw a painting over
here
it's do finish knife what the hell is
going to play so put him in the cab look
at cinema Tashkent guys do finish novel
Ken his old grandfather do French novel
cancer it was half German half American
do French novel can i press them
it's teasing me there it is my dude you
need a weapon
quite a sign bottle dude Epping
probably not much practice with preach
Chanukah
why
[Music]
captain midnight or at okay
yeah I should really take a look behind
this door should should what should i
that is the question yeah I should so
how do i pry this individual
[Music]
well I don't think we can use the lamp
but I'll touch it just to check it's got
some aftertaste
nothing door all right they used strange
words heft you guys ever use that word
[Music]
hey girl what's a hair bro I'm married
[Music]
married no thanks
swipe Knicks
Hey
hey I'm not gonna die - sometimes this
multi Hey
note that is what they know Dutchess
mati
say it with me in the chat notice what
they go away don't think so ugly toad
this matee hahah
where's your belly shoes totus
multiplaza floaty
damn you ugly oh haha damn you so ugly
that you look bad run
if I get caught then at least second
screw it but if I run I can do it quick
god I hate her how much
[Music]
this is epic
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
oh you are the worst
I think it's uglier isn't more as it
goes go back to twitch please
oh I don't want to donate to your
patreon
[Applause]
take your bathwater and go away yeah
that's right
[Music]
[Music]
Wow hesitancy I'm [ __ ] popping dare
no it's a trap oh my god is a trap it's
a double trap is it it's a double trap
is she ugly toad or a nice dog
oh god my brain it's a double trap it's
a double trap
okay gamers I'm gonna have their babies
are there thank you for smashing like
subscribing and epically epic on the
epic epic is snacking see you in next
episode it's much like and by the March
appreciate it well you haven't tried to
Bruce emulator citizen II after 50
million outros much go just now it's
still relevant just download it